the clock is ticking until thanksgiving
and that is just the beginning of what
becomes a very stressful season for so
many especially women cooking cleaning
entertainment a lot falls on mom so the
question is how do you get through the
holidays without feeling frazzled i
checked in with a local expert gallet
ventura rosen she is the author of the
successful woman's mindset and
co-founder of everyday woman and she
says it all begins with your mindset you
gotta let go the idea of perfection
and when i let go of this idea of
perfection and i recognize there's no
possible way i can get everything done
you think you can you can't because what
usually happens is you're so dang
exhausted you don't even get to enjoy
the holiday you don't even get to enjoy
the time so i'll give you a quick
example i used to be very very picky
about the dishes being done right away
after i cook right away after we now i
will leave the dishes until either that
night or the next morning one before it
used to make me crazy so there's certain
things that you can step away from just
so you can enjoy your time it is tough
to do but she says you have to do and a
smile can go a long way galit said find
some internal humor some of the things
that are happening around you and you
know if you find yourself in a
conversation at a gathering that's going
nowhere fast have a plan
remember that you don't have to respond
this is something that's almost like an
internal reaction
so a lot of times i'll literally
bite my tongue literally not just saying
oh bite your tongue or i'll close my
mouth
and i know it looks funny but sometimes
i was like i'm not gonna say anything in
my brain i'm not gonna say anything and
then a lot of times i'll excuse myself
heather
everybody always understands when you
have to go to the bathroom
yeah you know it's honesty right so
bottom line you got to find the joy
focus less on perfection and more on the
moments soak up the moments it's easier
said than done though you know
yes depending on who's sitting around
the dinner table well that's true we're
all to have a lot of bloody tongues